c'est un confetti au milieu de la
méditerranée un archipel minuscule plus
petit pays de l'union européenne plus
petits même que l'île de montréal un
pays sont l'accent rivière au climat
très aride
de tout temps les maths et ont dû
déployer des trésors d'ingéniosité pour
se fournir en eau en témoigne cet
aqueduc construit par les chevaliers au
xviie siècle à malte la seule source
naturelle dont et souterraines
mais elle n'est pas facilement
accessible ici attaquants dia il faut
descendre à 100 mètres sous terre pour
atteindre la nappe phréatique en dessous
du niveau de la mer les maths et ont
creusé des kilomètres de galeries dans
le calcaire pour puiser cette eau
cristalline
elle a longtemps constitué la principale
source doute pour tout l'archipel
mais depuis quelques années le niveau de
l'eau baisse dangereusement au milieu du
siècle dernier les mains thèses sont mis
à pomper massivement l'eau des nappes
phréatiques une ressource rapidement
victime de son succès il y à ce jour
plus de 8000 puis à travers l'archipel
les ingénieurs de la compagnie qui gère
l'eau de malte surveille attentivement
le niveau d'eau souterraine mais c'est
surtout sa qualité qui les inquiète
[Musique]
en surface l'image peut être trompeuse
les vallées verdoyantes à perte de vue
l'irrigation massive les puits et les
citernes d'eau peuvent donner
l'impression d'une ressource abondante
et l'agriculture intensive a un coût non
plus de vider les nappes phréatiques les
contamine aussi avec des nitrates issus
des engrais marco cremona tir depuis
longtemps la sonnette d'alarmé
cet ingénieur hydrologue milite pour une
utilisation plus responsable de la
ressource
côté réseau est grande
entourée d'eau c'est vers la
méditerranée que ces tournées l'archipel
pour régler son problème
d'approvisionnement en quelques années
le pays s'est doté d' usine gigantesque
de dessalement d'eau de mer comme celle
ci à pembroke qui peut produire 38
millions de litres d'eau douce par jour
grâce à la technologie de l'osm au
s'inverser elle fournit le tiers des
besoins du pays
mais la technologie n'a pas que des
qualités
tu vas le demande mondiale atrocités et
l'électricité à malte est produite
presque entièrement à partir
d'hydrocarbures importés autre problème
les besoins en eau sont croissants
depuis les années 70 la population a
augmenté de 50% et l'archipel accueille
chaque année près de deux millions de
touristes
oui selon l'hydrologue l'avenir passe
par une meilleure utilisation de la
ressource il y a dix ans l'île de gozo
s'est dotée d'une usine de retraitement
des eaux usées
objectif réduire la pollution des égouts
qui était auparavant rejeté directement
à la mer les bactéries dans ces immenses
bioréacteur permettent de traiter 6
millions de litres d'eau par jour de
l'eau plus propre qui était tout de même
perdu mais les choses sont sur le point
de changer
en contrebas de l'usiné d'épuration un
autre bâtiment vient d'être construit
l'eau usée y passent à travers ces
membranes et il subit un traitement
chimique pour en sortir claire et
limpide
l'objectif est de la distribuer aux
agriculteurs pour irriguer les champs
mais marco cremona est convaincu qu'il
faut aller encore plus loin dans cet
hôtel
il a installé un système de traitement
qui recycle l'eau des égouts pour en
faire de l'eau potable sont jusqu'ici
d'ordre politique et ont tout détruit
doivent être votées viol enquête sauvage
pour autant mise au point après des
années de recherches sur le système dit
il est écologique et surtout économique
malheureusement pour lui il est aussi en
avance sur son temps et n'a pas pu être
mises en service faute de feu vert des
autorités
et est ce qu'on sait de l'extrême droite
carcillo produite répond à toutes les
normes de sécurité
il lui reste encore à franchir l'étape
importante de l'opinion publique
une question de temps selon marco
cremona
rappel l'hydrologue recyclé de l'eau
n'est pas un concept nouveau
mère nature le fait depuis la nuit des
temps
[Musique]
et